it was WikiLeaks that made the headlines
that put Julian Assange on the front
cover
celebrities worldwide feted the
mysterious Australian as an
anti-establishment voice for good his
organization WikiLeaks was considered
whiter than its owner's hair an
independent untarnished truth seeker
that exposed shadowy practices the
British government has said Assange is
no hero but to his supporters that is
exactly what he is the reason people
like me stand behind jr. Sarge is
because at the heart of it WikiLeaks was
a project that says in a free democracy
that people have the right information
about their ruling elite acts and behave
Julian threatened most powerful beep in
the world with exposure and ordinary
people who thanks to Julian and
WikiLeaks I would many people now
understand a lot more about the cynicism
crushing a gun
one of Assange is best sources was the
former American soldier Chelsea Manning
he allegedly helped her hack the
Pentagon servers the resulting release
of millions of private diplomatic cables
sent WikiLeaks into a new dimension and
the US government into a spin
Washington's true thoughts on its allies
and foes alike were dramatically laid
bare for all to read and it was
WikiLeaks that reportedly helped Edward
Snowden leaked a vast cache of
intelligence documents the damage from
which continues to this day
in 2010 the Massiah image soured two
Swedish women accused Assange of sexual
assault and an arrest warrant was issued
court appearances in London became a
circus covered by media outlets from
across the globe
fearing extradition to the United States
Assange eventually sought asylum in the
Ecuadorian Embassy protesting his
innocence from inside since the very
beginning I have been saying please ask
me questions
a little submit a statement let me do a
video interview let me do a telephone
call etc and there has been a refusal
and there has been a refusal to give it
proper explanation is that even why
there's a refusal for seven years his
home was two small rooms on the first
floor of Ecuador's embassy until his
protector finally turned on him in the
mr. said we were obliged and a pervert
to put in written a set of norms for him
to behave properly an embassy and even
so he didn't act that way Julian Assange
is always denied working with Russia but
he increasingly set his sights on
America which fueled the theories of a
close relationship with Moscow he
remains headline news but not for the
same reasons as those early glory days
Alastair bungle Sky News